hello you're watching the daily climate
show on
sky news on today's programme will cuts
to the uk's
foreign aid budget undermine climate
discussions at cop26
the cost of climate change laid bare as
new research puts a price
on how much g7 countries could pay if
they don't do more to tackle the climate
crisis
and how a frozen food company is making
farming more sustainable one potato
field
at a time
[Music]
hello there and welcome to the uk's only
daily climate news show where we track
the changes
happening to our world right now and
meet those who are coming up with the
solutions
and we start today with concerns that a
cut to the uk's foreign aid budget will
undermine the country's presidency
of a key climate summit cop 26 as you
know takes place in glasgow in november
and a central part of the meeting will
of course be climate finance money from
richer countries
to help developing nations adapt to the
impacts of climate change
but the government is facing increasing
criticism of a decision to cut foreign
aid spending
which includes climate projects that's
from 0.7
of gross national income down to 0.5
well back in 2019 boris johnson
announced that the uk
would spend at least 11.6 billion pounds
on international climate finance
that's between 2021 and 2026.
well the foreign office says that this
year more than 500
million pounds will be spent on the
climate and biodiversity portfolio
and according to the government between
2011 and 2020 international climate
finance programs have supported
66 million people to cope with the
effects
of climate change well that includes
helping farmers to grow crops that can
adapt to changing weather conditions
improving irrigation systems and
strengthening defenses
against floods and storms well around 33
million people have been provided with
improved access to clean energy for
example more efficient cooking stoves
to reduce indoor air pollution from open
fires but will this be enough to
convince the critics well with me now is
our foreign affairs editor
deborah haynes deborah the optics of
this aren't great are they ahead of cop
26 when the uk government is going to be
encouraging other nations
to pony up cash for climate change
yes and the government is pushing back
against this obvious criticism saying
that it has
tried to protect funding for initiatives
that are related to climate change
because clearly
it is one of the government's core
priorities but
ahead of cop 26 ahead 2 of the g7 summit
this week
there's this huge criticism of the
government about these cuts
not only because it has an indirect
effect
on the battle to combat climate change
because
it reduces resources in the poorest
nations
for climate action but it also sends
exactly the wrong message when the
government is trying to get other
countries
to cough up and pay more it's cutting
its own budget
all right deborah thank you well let's
take a look now at today's other climate
news and if you fancy a change to your
commute then you could well
be in luck electric scooters are now
available to rent in some parts of
london
as part of a 12-month trial they're
limited though to 12 and a half miles
per hour and riders must be 18
or over research suggests that rental
e-scooters are better for the
environment than cars resulting in
approximately half
of the co2 emissions will norman is
london's walking and cycling
commissioner
we know that every day in london four
and a half million
car journeys are driven for less than
two kilometers so the challenge is
how can we switch people from using
those local car journeys to
walking cycling public transport and
this trial is looking at well what role
can e-scooters play in complementing
those modes
almost a quarter of all land mammals and
butterfly species are at risk in
cornwall that's according
to the cornwall wildlife trust who've
warned that 12 percent of species of
principal importance
are threatened with local extinction
they found that intensive farming and
climate change are among the biggest
threats to the county
while sea fishing and pollution are also
significant issues
also bad news for the african great apes
they're predicted to lose
90 percent of their habitats by 2050.
the study published in the journal
diversity and distributions found that
climate change
will cause the fruit and plants that
gorillas chimpanzees and bonobos eat
to grow elsewhere because great apes
reproduce slowly they have specific
diets
scientists say that 30 years isn't
enough time for them to migrate
and find new habitats now the economies
of g7 nations could see a huge hit
every year if they do not commit to
tackling climate change that is
according to new research
which suggests the climate crisis could
shrink economies by
twice as much as the kovid 19
well analysis from oxfam and the swiss
re institute shows that on average
gdp of g7 countries will decrease by
eight and a half percent
a year by 2050. that is equivalent to
almost
3.4 trillion pounds
however that is based on the most
drastic prediction of a global rise in
temperature of 2.6 degrees well here
is the effect on each of the g7 nations
the uk
is actually the least impacted projected
to lose
up to six and a half percent still of
gdp look at italy though
11.4 percent and france coming in at 10
both countries have no new national
level climate commitments beyond the
general eu target
of a reduction of 55 from 1990 levels by
the end of the decade
well to put the g7 nations into context
you can see here
how they compare to india a 27
hit to its economy the philippines down
35 percent well we can bring in here
nafcote derby climate policy lead at
oxfam
good afternoon to you uh nafcote and the
bottom line isn't it that
even with the climate pledges that we've
had
so far on reducing emissions climate
change is going to take a
big hit to economies around the world
thanks so much samantha that was a great
summary
uh i would not say you know the climate
plans
that we have right now are ambitious
we're
way off track from what is needed
actually uh to limit
a warming to 1.5 degrees centigrade
so we have less than nine years to
reduce emissions by half
and collectively you know globally we
need to reduce emissions
by half by 2030. and again we're way off
track
current climate plans current climate
policies
uh fall way below that uh from what is
needed to reduce
uh i mean to limit warming to 1.5 so 1.5
is what's considered to be safer to the
world
so actually you know the climate
ambition
right now is not uh to what
is needed to limit warming to 1.5
and this is why it's really critical at
this summit the g7 countries need to
take the lead
especially as you know they're
responsible
for historical emissions so they need to
take the lead to reduce emissions
faster and deeper yeah let me ask you
about that nafkate because
the climate finance that was promised by
richer nations more than 10 years ago
it hasn't materialized has it g7
countries or wealthy countries
uh are falling short of you know the 100
billion commitment
uh as of now uh you know we think around
uh eighty percent of the funding has
been met
uh but there's more that needs to be
done and this finance is not enough to
uh what is needed
to support especially communities that
are highly vulnerable uh
to the climate crisis so more needs to
be done
all right well we'll have to wait and
see when we and i've got it i'll be good
to talk to you thank you
thank you so much samantha farming is
often criticized when it comes to
climate change
land is cleared to plant crops
greenhouse gas emissions are produced by
livestock
and fertilizers can cause environmental
damage
but one company trying to make a
difference is mccain
food the frozen potato company has
committed to improving their farming
practices
by using 100 regenerative farming
by 2030. well here is how
that works
[Music]
[Music]
well that's how it all works we can talk
more about it now with daniel
meatheringham
vice president of agriculture at mccain
afternoon
to you daniel this is a big change in
the way that you're going to do
business what prompted it what prompted
it i think
this year is an absolutely crucial year
uh
for farming um government um and also
all of our
our farmers and business and what we've
decided to do
is make a real ambitious pledge uh
to move all of our farmers to 100
regenerative
practices by 2030 and that is globally
so we really are trying to set the bar
high
and a firm of your size your global how
do you monitor
these commitments across thousands of
farms in
six continents yeah look we work on a
global scale
and we have a global agriculture program
that we basically work work towards
and part of that is actually by
leveraging what we're
announcing also is operating three farms
of the futures by 2025
and what these will be are basically
knowledge transfer hubs
uh for all of our farmers and customers
uh to basically go on and see these
practices in hand
and then look at how we're monitoring
using technology to leverage that data
so then we can basically improve the
soils
and basically increase biodiversity and
reduce greenhouse gases
now we all know there's a pretty tight
margin in the modest old potato
at daniel and farmers have had a tough
year as you say
are consumers going to end up paying
more for their fries
um i think it's difficult to say about
the the the total value but this is
about billion building resilience
in into the businesses so uh mccain is a
family owned business
um it was founded by farmers and
basically
what we've seen over the last few years
is greater volatility in the potato
market
so and the climate extremes we've been
experiencing
has been really impacting both mccain
and the farmer
so building in that resilience i think
the cost
element that will actually stabilize and
create a stable environment to work in
all right daniel really good to talk to
you thank you for your time on
sky news thank you well that is
everything from us for today join us
tomorrow though when we've got special
coverage of
world ocean day including the fishermen
who are being taught how to remove
plastic
from the mediterranean sea that's at the
same time tomorrow
here of course on sky news hope to see
[Music]
them